Forget the Big Bang… we might have had the
Big Bounce instead!
The Big Bounce hypothesis says that before
the universe as we know it today had formed,
there was a universe here before us.
It disappeared before we arrived in something
called the Big Crunch.
And from there it created such an immense
amount of density and extreme temperatures
that it caused an inversion effect meaning
it went from the big crunch right into expansion,
and formed the universe as we know it today--no
point of singularity, no Big Bang required.
This is referred to as the bounce.
If our universe formed through a bounce instead
of a Big Bang then maybe some of what exists
in the current universe today has already
existed in a previous one!
The bounce hypothesis arose from our understanding
of black holes.
It all started when physicist James Berdeen,
in 1968, modified the equations about black
holes in Einstein’s theory of General Relativity.
He stated that the mass of a black hole is
not constant but instead a function based
off the distance to the center of the black
hole.
This gave birth to the possibility of a new
kind of black hole: named the “regular”
black hole which does not violate general
relativity…
The idea has been around for decades.
So if there are black holes with no singularity
then maybe there’s no singularity for the
universe either!
This maybe can be the basis of the Universe
Bounce hypothesis.
Many scientists, like physicist Juliano Cesar
Silva Neves, believe that a black hole isn’t
identified by its singularity but instead
by its event horizon…. which is the area
around the black hole, where, once an object
passes by it, it’s doomed for a one way
ticket into the black hole.
He believes that spacetime acts totally differently
at the event horizon than elsewhere in the
universe.
And there may be something there that can
explain some of the questions that arise in
the bounce hypothesis.
He also believes in the possibility that some
of the black holes in our universe existed
before the big crunch and transferred over
to our current universe during the inversion
process.
Does that mean maybe we too existed in another
universe before this one?!?!
Well, until more research is done this is
just a mere mathematical possibility.
But it’s still pretty amazing to think about…
right?
To learn more about spacetime phenomena please
subscribe to our channel!
And check out this video on black holes!
Starting in the 1940s scientists have constructed
3 potential outcomes of our universe: The
big crunch, the infinite expansion and the
stagnation expansion.